wenn es gut läuft sind Klausurtagungen
in Meseberg so etwas wie eine politische
Klassenfahrt Landflucht aus dem
ampelalltag aber es läuft nicht gut im
Gegenteil die Regierung nervt sich
blockiert sich streitet sich bis nichts
mehr vorangeht der Grünen würden uns
manchmal weniger Streit in der
Öffentlichkeit wünschen die Angriffe auf
mich gehen ja von den Grünen aus ich
glaube die Bürgerinnen und Bürger stehen
nicht da drauf wenn das
regierungspersonal in der Öffentlichkeit
die ganze Zeit den Eindruck vermittelt
als seien viele Fragen noch offen
tatsächlich stauen sich die Streitfragen
bedenklich dutzende Projekte hängen fest
von der planungsbeschleunigung über das
Waffenrecht bis zur Pflegereform mal
geht es ums Geld oft geht es um
taktisches blockieren und sehr oft geht
es grün gegen gelb und Geld gegen grün
besonders deutlich in der
Verkehrspolitik soll Bio Sprit verboten
werden welche Zukunft hat der
Verbrennermotor immer wollen grün und
FDP genau das Gegenteil des anderen im
ewig Streit um planungsbeschleunigten
Straßen oder schienbeinbau ist gerade
der nächste lösungstermin geplatzt
stattdessen Sticheleien und politische
frustfaults
also wir würden unsere Koalitionspartner
einladen nächste Woche Gesetze zum Thema
planungsbeschleunigung bei Schiene und
Brücken in den Deutschen Bundestag
einzubringen wenn man versucht alles mit
allen zu verhandeln dann verlangsamt das
natürlich Entscheidungen naja bei der
planungsbeschleunigung im Straßenbau
halten die Grünen dagegen und Bremsen
und deswegen habe ich daran erinnert
dass wir uns nicht in ideologisch Graben
Kämpfe verlieren sollten
wo immer der Koalitionsvertrag nicht
eindeutig formuliert ist und er ist oft
nicht eindeutig formuliert legen die
ampelpartner ihn gegensätzlich aus
aktuell auch beim Thema Kinder
Grundsicherung die FDP will vor allem
bisherige Sozialleistungen leichter
zugänglich machen die grüne
Familienministerin will die Leistung mit
deutlich mehr Geld ausstatten und dafür
ca 12 Milliarden Euro aus dem
Bundeshaushalt
also einfach nur mehr Geld rein zu tun
bringt ja nichts wenn das Geld nicht
ankommt es kann ja nicht sein dass
Eltern zu Hause Aktenordnern sammeln
müssen und Papiere unterschreiben müssen
sondern ein digitales Portal das ist ja
das was wir uns auch vereinbart haben da
müsste die Familienministerin jetzt auch
liefern sie hat ja zugesagt dass sowas
kommt da erwarte ich jetzt schon ein
bisschen Geschwindigkeit ich finde ich
habe erhebliche Geschwindigkeit gezeigt
seitdem ich mal an bin arbeite ich an
der Kindergrundsicherung und habe den
Zeitplan noch einmal beschleunigt es
braucht jetzt tatsächlich politische
Beschlüsse ich habe die Grundlage gelegt
andere sind jetzt dran dass wir uns
gemeinsam einigen gemeint ist der
Finanzminister die FDP sei nach vielen
verlorenen Wahlen profilierungssüchtig
sagen die Grünen die Grünen seien
unverschämt in den Ansprüchen meint die
fdpd Verein sind beide im Ärger aufs
Kanzleramt Olaf Scholz müsse keine Macht
Worte sprechen aber sprechen müssen er
schon Prozesse steuern Blockaden lösen
stattdessen schaut Scholz zu wie sich
die beiden kleineren ampelpart immer
weiter ineinander verbeißen die SPD ist
nicht der Schiedsrichter in dieser
Regierung sondern wir sind der stärkste
Koalitionspartner und natürlich haben
wir eine eigene Position aber die
koalitionsverhandlung die hatten wir ja
schon mal die haben im Herbst 2021
stattgefunden das Ergebnis daraus ist
der Koalitionsvertrag und daher ist
zumindest unser Anspruch dass nicht
andauernd alles neu verhandelt wird
sondern dass wir jetzt abarbeiten was
wir uns dort vorgenommen haben
kurz nach Meseberg sollen die Eckpunkte
für die nächsten Bundeshaushalt stehen
rund 70 Milliarden Euro an Zusatz
wünschen haben die Kabinettskollegen bei
Christian Lindner hinterlegt der aber
winkt ab mit Verweis auf die
Schuldenbremse mit mehr Geld so scheint
es wird die Ampel ihre vielen Gräben
nicht zu schütten können
und bei mir im Studio ist jetzt einer
der Ampel Chefs der Parteivorsitzende
der Grünen guten Abend und guten
ja eigentlich als jemand der
gebetsmühlenartig sagt das alles ganz
prima und hinter den Kulissen verstehen
hinter uns sehr gut jetzt fühlen wir von
zwei Quellen aus dem Kabinett das Robert
Habeck gesagt hat der
Vertrauensvorschuss ist jetzt
ausgeschüttet ausgegeben was sagt uns
das über die Ampel ich habe letzte Woche
in der Pressekonferenz gehabt da hatte
Kollegin von ihnen gefragt wie ist das
mit dem einen milliardentopf kann man
das so oder so machen und meine erste
Frage war was für welchen der vielen
milliardentöpfe meinen Sie denn
eigentlich ich erzähle diese Geschichte
weil sie ein Stückchen darstellt dass
die Tragweite der Entscheidungen die wir
zu treffen haben gewaltig ist und auch
nicht nur in dieser Kriegssituation
sondern über Jahre dieses Land prägen
wird und da miteinander nicht immer
gleicher Meinung zu sein ist zu weinen
gar nicht so falsch wir müssen natürlich
gucken dass es eingedämmt ist und das
ist ähm im Rahmen läuft aber dass man
bei der Tragweite der Entscheidungen
tatsächlich auch mal erstmal streiten
muss und diskutieren muss das normal ja
das ist ja hat ja das letzte Jahr auch
geprägt aber wenn der
Vertrauensvorschuss jetzt aufgebraucht
ist
ist ja offensichtlich einiges passiert
was vorher nicht der Fall war es gibt
Vertrauensvorschuss und es gibt
natürlich auch Vertrauen das wächst wenn
man miteinander gut zusammenarbeitet und
es ist auch einiges gewachsen im letzten
Jahr und jetzt gilt es dass wir wieder
in diesen Arbeitsmodus zurückkommen wir
haben die entlassungspakete miteinander
auf dem Weg gebracht viele viele große
Entscheidungen getroffen und am Ende des
Tages müssen wir natürlich auch uns
immer wieder besinnen dass wir als
Koalition immer wieder geliefert haben
und das ist das Spirit mit dem wir
vorankommen ich gebe zu da sind wir
gerade nicht ich habe
kann das nicht verbergen habe auch kein
Interesse daran aber dass wir
miteinander können das haben wir in den
letzten 12 Monaten hier das eine oder
andere Mal ich finde ziemlich gut
gezeichnet war ein Beispiel der liberale
Finanzminister wahrscheinlich da gerade
dem grünen Wirtschaftsminister mit Blick
auf die heizungspläne er soll noch mal
die Montage aller gehen für eine
grundsätzliche Bearbeitung was nervt sie
bei den Liberalen mehr tun oder mehr
Inhalt wie gesagt bei Inhalten kommen am
Ende immer zusammen und ich finde ich
würde super gerne mit Christian Lindner
zusammen mal durcheinander Montagehalle
gehen ich glaube das tut uns beiden gut
aber ein bisschen anzufassen und auch
was zu lernen von den Handwerkerinnen
Handwerkern dort wir haben zusammen
diese die das was wir jetzt gerade
kritisiert beschlossen es steht im
Koalitionsvertrag die Frage war 24 oder
25 da haben wir verschiedene Beschlüsse
gefasst nacheinander wenn wir jetzt
nicht dazu kommen dass zum Beispiel
Ölheizungen oder Gasheizungen einfach
die neu gebaut werden und es geht
überhaupt nicht um die Idee jetzt gerade
sind es geht überhaupt nicht um den
Bestand aber 24
ganz ehrlich ich finde 24 richtig ist
Robert habe 24 richtig aber der
Grundsatz ist doch ein anderer der
Grundsatz ist dass wir dahin kommen
müssen dass wir bei den nächsten
Generationen an Heizungen die eingebaut
werden auch Klimaschutz betreiben eine
Heizung die 30 Jahre oder 20 Jahre läuft
und zwar auch fossilen komplett heißt
dass wir das nächste Mal machen 2045
oder 55 das kann sich niemand leisten
und die e-fuels die die FDP gerade in
Europa aufhält Frau von der Leyen ist ja
jetzt gerade in Meseberg da gilt das
selber wir haben da miteinander für
Dinge vereinbart wir haben
in ganz Europa tatsächlich auch
Abstimmungen mit vorangebracht jetzt
sind wir in der allerletzten Kurve und
Deutschland hat verlässlicher Partner
auf den sich die anderen 26 verlassen
haben sollte da auch stehen und
gleichzeitig hören wir auch von der
Automobilindustrie die jetzt eigentlich
auch mitten in den Planungen sind all
dessen was Europa seit Jahren sagt und
vorgibt dass sie auch jetzt da
vorankommen können das heißt sie sagen
der FDP was dass wir sicher für alles
eine Lösung finden das ist alles nicht
so dramatisch ist und das ist schwierig
das ist die Anlage das ist nicht
diplomatisch das ist für unser aller
fängt Schulhaushalt von guten nutzen
wenn wir ein bisschen wenn wir ein
bisschen abrüsten nach draußen und und
den den Geister der Zusammenarbeit den
wir nach ihnen ja miteinander gezeigt
haben auch tatsächlich aufnehmen
Stichwort Kindergrundsicherung reichen
Ihnen die Milliarden die der
Finanzminister angeboten hat Frau Paus
sagte sie braucht 12 im 12 Milliarden
jedes Jahr er sagt ein einstelliger
Betrag da wird das Gespräch gegeben und
am Ende wird man zu einer Lösung kommen
entscheidend ist dass wir in einem der
reichsten Länder der Welt einfach ist
endlich schaffen Kinderarmut was
wirklich eine Schande ist einzudämmen
und das ist eine Baustelle wo ich
relativ sicher bin dass wir eine gute
Lösung miteinander finden ich habe auch
sagen wir mal Bewegungsspielräume von
von der Seite des Finanzminister
zumindest vernommen dass wir danken und
freue mich das Ergebnis kann ich nicht
vorwegnehmen aber das heißt ein
einstelliger Milliardenbetrag wäre für
sie nicht akzeptabel wenn die Ministerin
sagt sie braucht 12 Milliarden wir
werden am Ende miteinander eine Lösung
haben jetzt sich auf Zahlen festzulegen
wäre von meiner Seite falsch die
Ministerin formuliert das was gebraucht
wird und natürlich wollen wir alles
dafür tun damit Kinderarmut in diesem
Land
der Vergangenheit angehört als beides
geht oder zumindest massiv eingedämmt
wird auch das haben wir zusammen im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbar sind 70
Milliarden mehr Bedarf angemeldet worden
beim Finanzminister worauf würden Sie
denn an grünen Projekten verzichten wir
haben einen Dreieck insgesamt zusammen
als Koalition was Druck macht auf den
Haushalt das ist die Schuldenbremse das
ist die die Krisensituation massiv
beschleunigt und wir haben ein hohes
ambitionslevel damit sind wir zusammen
angetreten wir haben im
digitalisierungsbereich alleine immense
Kosten zu bewerkstelligen und ich würde
jetzt nicht sagen Digitalisierung gehört
den einen Klimaschutz gehört den anderen
sondern diese Regierung muss dieses Land
nach vorne bringen und deshalb gilt es
dass wir zusammen die Projekte die es
braucht damit dieses Land endlich
krisenfest ist auch zusammenziehen da
war kein Angebot von ihnen zu streichen
ich halte aber fest aber immer noch
einmal es gibt keine grünen
haushaltspunkte es gibt die der
Bundesregierung vielen Dank ich nehme
mit dass es Bewegung gibt bei der
Kindergrundsicherung herzlichen Dank
danke